hey youtubers is Charlie really awesome
news they just premiered the Vixen
animated series so this is gonna be my
video for that now what they're doing
with it is a little bit different from
normal TV show so I'll just I'll explain
what's going on first if you have
absolutely no idea what I'm talking
about
vixen is a character from DC Comics
she's been like a minor Justice League
character for a long time she's been in
almost like 500 issues she was supposed
to be their first african-american
character ever in the comics way way way
back but DC Comics went through
something called their implosion where
they canceled like all their titles like
every single title they had rebooted
everything so the character didn't end
up actually debuting till the early
1980s in action comics but she went out
to be really powerful Justice League
member her powers flow from a totem it
allows her to channel the powers of
nature she's kind of like Animal Man or
you know if you want to take the totem
route kind of like Black Panther and
that Black Panthers powers flow from his
Panther totem but functionally on-screen
what it looks like when she's using her
powers is she's just channeling the
powers of different animals like the
power of flight super speed like a
cheetah you get the idea so they did six
episodes of this animated series it's
basically an origin story for her it's
like a new take on the character a new
introduction it's six five-minute
episodes that are kind of intended to
make one big 30-minute episode some of
you might be scratching your heads you
know like why did they only do six
five-minute episodes
well the CW isn't like rolling in cash
and it costs a ton of money to do a full
new series like to do a bunch of
30-minute episodes and they just they
kind of want to try the character out so
this is kind of like a soft pilot
program if it's successful enough they
said that the character will go to
live-action so what we might see next is
is the actress that they cast to do the
voice role actually kind of looks like
she belongs on the flash and arrow so
they would let her go on like Barry
Allen went on arrow that was actually
kind of a test like Barry Allen debuted
in a two-part episode and it was so
popular they were like okay give it its
own pilot so they'll do the same thing
with vixen if they think it's popular
enough so I encourage you please support
this show now what they're doing is
because it's digital it's on their CW
seed service it's not airing on
television they just they post an
episode and it's going to be up forever
so you can watch episode one as many
times as you want if you live outside
the US you might have to use a V
p.m. workaround like if you've ever
tried to watch the BBC iplayer and you
don't live in Great Britain that's
probably how you're gonna have to watch
vixen because I don't know that they're
making it available internationally
remember this is kind of just like a
pilot program it's not like a full-blown
show I just ask that you guys don't post
pirate streaming links but you know feel
free to explain to people how they can
watch it just just write the text don't
paste links in the comments what's going
on in this episode well it kind of jumps
around in time you open up and she's
being chased by flashing arrow that's
just to let you know that they're
crossing over like this is a full-blown
crossover with arrow in the flesh
Stephen Amell and Grant Gustin both did
their voices it's been a long time since
I've heard Stephen Amell do like
full-blown arrow voice he was on
SummerSlam recently and even though his
voice got really deep he didn't do like
the full-blown arrow voice if you don't
recognize it right away they say it in
the episode they call it Motor City
they're in Detroit that's where this is
taking place and in the timeline this is
somewhere around arrow season 3 episode
16 that's why Oliver is still wearing
his old costume so don't be surprised if
they talk about vixen in arrow season 3
in the flash season two like if they
make a reference to her a woman who
channels the powers of animals arrow is
getting really heavy into mysticism in
season four so vixen is kind of like the
soft intro to that in that her powers
flow from a magical source so the
episode jumps around a time a little bit
it kind of seems like she's a criminal
like they're just kind of playing with
you a little bit people who have read
about her in the comics know that she's
a hero so this is just meant to be like
a fun new take on the character like she
feels like she's the last person that
would become a hero and she really
doesn't know anything about her heritage
or her powers she doesn't understand how
the totem works yet so about halfway
through this episode it jumps to three
days previously and she's also getting
out of prison so you can just see that
she gets into a lot of trouble I would
say the closest thing we've seen to like
an antihero female character is golden
glider and she's closer to being a
villain the way she was portrayed in
season 1 she's a little more sinister
more Dee McCabe is also kind of morally
great right now but she's closer to the
hero side so what's going to happen is I
think the only other character that I
know about from flash and arrow that's
going to cross over is Cisco just
because he appeared in the trailers but
what they're going to do is each
Tuesday they'll just I'll post a new
episode and you can watch so we'll
probably see Cisco next week and they'll
be like who is this woman why does she
have powers I'm gonna call her vixen
that's the fun part is that Cisco gives
her her name you guys can let me know
though have you ever read vixen in the
comics and what do you think about the
idea of the CW using this like animated
short program to test pilot characters
for live-action what might end up
happening is is even if it doesn't go to
live-action they don't make like a
full-blown live-action vixen TV series
they would keep doing the animated short
and they would bring the character on
the live-action show once or twice a
season that was actually the plan for
Barry Allen like if the flash cameo
during arrow season two didn't work out
if they didn't decide to go forward on
the pilot then Barry out like grant
gustin's character would just keep
coming on arrow as a guest star kind of
like what's going on with Constantine
right now so be sure and support vixen
tweet the out of it she's an
awesome character and I'm actually
really happy that they're trying this
alternate program people always wonder
why they don't just put more shows on TV
The CW can only program about 10 hours
of TV per week that's all they have
money for so that's why you're not
seeing them just like throw a bunch of
the TV shows up on the air right away
they've already got their fall and
spring schedules planned out so it's
winter for legends of tomorrow premieres
they're actually going to have to
postpone one of their other shows coming
back it's already a pretty big logjam of
awesome characters so really big news
for the flash though they just cast
Jesse quick that's right new female
speedster on the flash season two I'm
gonna do a separate video just for her
explaining her comic book history so be
sure to subscribe to get that I have a
couple of the videos that I'm trying to
get to today but I wanted to explain
like what was going on with casting the
actors that they cast is violet bean you
may not know her before she's mostly
been doing horror stuff so that should
tell you a lot about which direction
they're going this season the flash
horror show that would be so awesome
what's happening is is they're going to
introduce her as a college student that
just gets caught up in the Flash's
battle with zoom so count them off we
have two female speedsters although
technically iris West did get flash
powers for a brief period but patty
spivot female flash she was actually two
different female flashes and now Jessie
quick so here's what the schedule is
going to be for the next couple of
videos I'm going to do my fear The
Walking Dead Q&A
then I'll do this flash video and then
I'll do my Game of Thrones QA so
everything's going to post I'll try to
get this stuff out as quick as possible
if you follow me on Twitter and Facebook
I'll actually have updates on the videos
is that as I work through them the links
for that are in the description below so
really awesome week we're pretty much
like TV is pretty much back now so if
you guys haven't seen it yet you can
click here for fear The Walking Dead
episode 1 and you can click here for all
my flash season 2 videos so many new
characters coming you guys have no idea
how awesome it's going to be thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you